now to the rising tensions between the
United States and China highlighted in
two recent close calls on Saturday
Chinese warship crossed in front of an
American destroyer in the Taiwan Strait
and last week a Chinese fighter jet flew
across the path of a U.S plane causing
turbulence Elizabeth Palmer is following
all of this from Tokyo Liz good morning
can you explain what's going on here
good morning this close call on the high
seas was not only dangerous it was
caught on video by a journalist for the
whole world to see and it happened just
as the U.S and China's top defense
officials had been in the same room at
the same conference which on any other
day wouldn't have attracted a lot of
attention
China's General Lee Shang Fu used his
first high-profile International
appearance to address the weekend's
incident with some blunt advice for the
U.S
keep your ships and planes away he was
referring to this a close call on
Saturday when a Chinese warship crossed
the course of an American Destroyer so
close it had to slow down to avoid a
collision last week a Chinese fighter
jet cut across the flight path of a U.S
reconnaissance plane General Lee didn't
address the Chinese decision-making that
led to the incidents but implied the U.S
was ultimately responsible
to avoid similar encounters he said the
U.S should steer clear of the area
around China mind your own business
air and sea patrols as very much its own
business where China's flexing military
muscle in the Pacific
America and its allies want to
underscore their position that this is
International Space open to everyone
at a banquet on Friday generally did
shake hands with the American Secretary
of Defense Lloyd Austin but China had
already decided against a formal meeting
something the administration is still
pushing hard for in spite of overall
Chile relations in a cordial handshake
over dinner is no substitute for a
substantive engagement
we'll probably see more of that mixed
messaging for some time but on a more
constructive note there are two
Administration officials in Beijing
right now having meetings so it's not
out of the question that we'll see a
direct President Biden president XI talk
sometime later this year Gail
always good to have a constructive note
thank you Liz Palma reporting from Tokyo